this week was focused on meetings I just
had a call with a client and I've also
developed a few pans using flexbox and
sauce I practice another you I are
elements to using flexbox
[Music]
I just got the pointer because because
grid layout and it's not ready for
production yet because it's not
supported by the browsers and so well
let's see before why maybe I'll
connected somewhere in the future this
is that able to be easily else no much
have set
traveling here in Spain you see how much
you lose when you don't change
one place
and that love is
all around you the same is improving
when you stay in one language when you
don't try another stuff when you can try
another framework
you get stuck
don't get out of your comfort
you cannot easily close
Zac pages humble scribe and
design all right
I'm gonna do yeah
I hate we are
specializing in one is late but being
aware of what's around you and triangle
things is even better
variety has its reason and not
and stay clear
so the fact that you take turns up
doesn't mean that your program in the
diagonal
through all your life
suggesting to this one frame normal
language and that's right anything new
five years
cuz I getting old habit because ideas
fast-paced branch that we have to be at
least aware of what's going on
especially if you work on projects
relating and the site or your team
member has an influence on
seeing the frame or of the solution that
it's like if you are not aware of what
arrangement what's better for what
thank you choose and suggest your plans
yeah well go for dudes you know frame or
go this
jump straight to it just only because
you know it not just because it's the
best one great at holidays is always
almost finished because all of the knee
that start living again so this week I'm
going to yes we tag we are triangles on
organized and next from the malaga and
another coffee and called meeting there
are at least three kinds of meetings
worth considering while learning to code
number one meetups at this page meetup
com you can find local meetups that are
being organized in your city or you know
close to your city its first day today
I'm going toward the first unofficial
meeting of years we check this season
yes we take its focus on diversity and
equality in dec shall we begin
[Music]
[Music]
number two project meetings I love this
book it's revived by Driessen feet and
ehh as they say meetings are toxic if
you look they also give their quick
simple rules how to you know deal with
meetings this is the list server timer
when it rains meeting is over period so
you know the schedule amount of time
that you really want to devote to the
meeting it would be perfect invite as
few people as possible and always have a
clear agenda begin with a specific
problem meet at the site of the problem
instead of a conference room point
oriole thanks and suggesting changes
every resolution and make someone
responsible for implementing it we
things are like time Steelers and when I
need with a client to talk about the
project I tried firstly to corporate and
to prepare the ground for it to send him
some list of questions pasty and to
discuss just only the doubt and you know
some unexpected things that he hadn't
mentioned so far I'm lying it I read it
also is how to schedule the meetings in
order to be more productive with them
and in order to get as much as possible
from them I just had a call with a
client and I'm super happy and I want to
share with you that why i want to share
it is because it's just another thing
about being pronounced rams developer
the thing is that because of asking
properly the questions because of
clarifying the details because of making
from the general concept something else
tangible we reach the solution that
seems to be really really awesome and
really interesting to design connecting
learning with working as a freelancer is
seems to be really nice
solution because you have extra time for
learning but also you know money to
survive and it gives you the real the
real life experience outs just going for
smaller projects and for for the task
that you really feel no at least
comfortable with they should be
challenging they should be challenging
in order to make you grow in order to
make a develop and in order to light
their way again you know the projects
make them inspiring also for you this
real live experience it's like a real
training before bigger projects and the
good jobs remember that you don't need
permission to start coding to start
designing to start freelancing and to
start taking projects and to start in a
working with clients being self-aware
and being reliable you can really start
doing it right now and the third type of
meetings off topic so meetings with
friends and meeting janeiro connected
with your hobbies it is connected with
staying alive in other fields of life
there's myths about people who close
themselves and you know in like in
cabinet and eat should repeat them
simply learn coding in order to stay
focused but is another way for me to do
it and I need variety in order to say
motivated in order to learn coffee isn't
the fewer of my coat a variety is
chapter 6 p.m. and i'm going out to to
the next meeting this week and in order
to is the time on my way I've been
listening to the podcast
I've just finished listening to the
podcast to the last date night with
travel noise about productivity and
about self-awareness is where you are
recommending in order to stay motivated
you cannot sit all the time in front of
the screen you have to go out we are
trying to find the gift for our friends
will be more tonic and we are also
presented for Peralta
[Music]
this week I took part in few meetings
and was trying to organize till next the
main problem of this week display grid
and the fact that it's not supported by
the browser's I gather few brownies are
having other people on dinner but also i
need some more to reach my 500 ground
challenge so i will keep on helping
other people next week next week i will
have to put the priority to the new
project that i'm starting connected with
designed but from learning to code and
my personal learning to current projects
i will start implementing the new
portfolio using flexbox and SAS keep on
doing go for productive meetings and see
you soon
[Music]